ونحييكم من جديد الصراع على خلافه المرشد
الايراني علي خامنئي عاد الى السطح ولكن
هذه المره بشكل يبدو خفيا وباسماء مختلفه
فالصراعوا تقوده بصمت المؤسسه العسكريه في
مقابلها الجناح المتشدد المعروف بجماعه
الثابتون والشخصيه القويه في سعيد جليل
الذي يعارض على نان توجهات المرشد
باستئناف المفاوضات النوويه هذا التيار هو
وفق مراقبين دعم ابراهيم رئيسي في
انتخابات الرئاسه ويحتل الان مواقع مقرره
في الحكومه ما ينعش الامل لدى رئيس بالفوز
في مقعد المرشد ويوضح خبراء بان المنظومه
الامنيه والعسكريه تشترك مع تيار الثابتون
باليه واحده لتحقيق الهدف ولكن باسلوبين
مختلفين فالمنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه تسعى
ربما الافتعال وتوظيف الاوضاع الامنيه
لدفع مصادر قلقها الى ظهور ومن ثم القضاء
عليها في حين حاول جماعه اسابيتون ايهام
الشارع بان مصدر ازماته هو الغرب بالتالي
فان التيار ومرشحه الاقدر على بناء مستقبل
ايران يفرض نفسه ويضيف مراقبون بان الصراع
على السلطه في ايران لن يقتصر على تلك
الجهات فمراكز قوه اخرى ستدخل في المستقبل
على خط التنافس والصراع نناقش هذا الموضوع
مع ضيوفنا من بيروت حسن فحص الكاتب الصحفي
اهلا بك من الرياض صالح حميد الباحث في
شان الايراني اهلا بكم ضيوفي اسمحوا لي ان
ابدا من بيروت معك استاذ حسن لطالما كنا
نتحدث عن ترابط شديد وتكامل شديد بين رجال
الدين ورجال الجيش او العسكر في داخل
الايراني اليوم وكانه هناك صوره جديده
وكانه هناك طرف من هذه الاطراف يدفع الى
الظفر بسياده النظام بمفرده هل هذه الرؤيه
صحيحه
تحياتي اهلا بك الكريم استاذ صالح
والمشاهدين يعني انت وصلت للخلاصات
النهائيه في
المقالب خلينا نبدا من الاول خلينا نبدا
نفهمها من الاول معك كيف تم ذلك كيف حصل
يعني
المساله الذاهبه باتجاه ان تدفع المؤسسه
العسكريه للفصل مع المؤسسه الدينيه
والسيطره على النظام هذا باعتقادي يعني
حسب المؤشرات الموجوده والتي باتت ملموسه
ايضا
يعني ان المستقبل لهذه لهذه الشراكه هو
الانفصال لان المؤسسه العسكريه ترى ان
المؤسسه الدينيه او وجوه المؤسسه الدينيه
اخذت فرصتها في قياده النظام وفي السيطره
على مفاصل النظام وبالتالي
انتهى هذا هذا التعايش او هذا الزواج
وممكن ان ان تنتقل الامور الى حسم
ومحاصره المؤسسه الدينيه واعادتها الى
دورها التقليدي
والامساك بضمام الامور والسيطره على
النظام والتحكم به كيف ما تريد مثل
المؤسسه العسكريه يعني لذلك
انتهى انتهيت انت في في الخلاصه التي
قدمتها الى النهايات المسار الذي تذهب
اليه المؤسسه العسكريه في التعاطي مع
مساله خلافه المرشد والمستقبل ايران استاذ
صالح اذا تم فعليا هذا الطلاق واذا كنت
توافق وترى كذلك من جهتك بان هناك يعني هو
كبير هناك طلاق ات بين هذين الطرفين كيف
ستكون تداعيات خاصه واننا نعلم بان السلطه
ان كانت مغلفه بالدين فهي قويه ان كانت
مغلفه بالقوه بالجيش فقد تكون اقوى
تحياتي لك يا استاذه ريم والاستاذ حسن
المشاهدين الكرام في الواقع يجب ان نعود
قليلا الى الوراء لكي نفهم الحاله
الايرانيه وهذا ما اسميتيه
بالتمازج او التزاوج بين العسكر والمؤسسه
الدينيه فالحقيقه اعتقد ان احدهما يعتمد
على الاخر ولا يستطيع احدهما الاستمرار
بدون الاخر لانه اساسا تشكيل الحرس الثوري
والذي يمسك الان بزمام
الاقتصاد وقسم كبير من السياسه ونجد
الامنيه في البلاد يعود فكرته اساسا الى
حمايه النظام الثوري وتشكيله اصلا اسمه
حتى
يعني لا يحمل اسم ايران اسمه
حرس الثوره الاسلاميه بدون اسم ايران هذا
الاسم الرسمي يعني فلسفه تشكيل الحرس هو
اولا حمايه النظام وثانيا مشروع النظام
المتمثل بامبراطوريه ولايه الفقيه اي ما
عرف بتصدير الثوره لذلك حتى لو يعني تغير
المرشد او المرشد او خلف ابنه او احد اخر
صحيح انه سيكون هناك دور حاسم للحرس
الثوري باعتباره خلال خاصه العشرين عامل
الاخيره
يعني باقي يمسك بالكثير من الاوراق في
البلاد لكن لا اعتقد ان احدهما يستطيع
الاستغناء عن الاخر بمعنى انه
المؤسسه الدينيه هي التي اوجدت الحرس
الثوري ولا تزال يعني هذه المؤسسه وخاصه
التيار المتجدد فيها رغم انه تخلى عن قسم
كبير من خطابه لكنه لا يزال يمسك بزمام
السلطه السلطات الثلاث المؤسسات في البلاد
بالاضافه الى المؤسسات الموازيه للدوله
التي يسيطر عليها مراجع ورجال دين متشددين
اغلبهم موالون للمرشد ولكن صالح من كل
الاسماء هي هناك اسماء وشخصيات متعدده في
الواقع قيل بانها قادره ان تخلف المرشد من
كل هذه الاسماء انت ذكرت الابن
وكنت حاضر معنا في حلقات اخرى واكدت على
انه من اكبر المرشحين باختصار قبل ان انقل
هذه الكلمه الاستاذ حسن لماذا هذا
الاعتقاد
لانه عمليا يعني اضعف كل المنافسين نجله
مجتبى وطدا صلاته
بالحرس الثوري حتى يعني محمد
مدير مكتب المرشد قال في تصريح سابق انه
خامنئي اول بعد صلاحياته لمجتبى لمجتبى
الان حصل على درجه المستند من الحوزه
وهناك تمهيد له بينما المنافسون الاخرون
مثل لا رجالي وغيره يعني تمت ازالتهم من
السلطه واخرون كانوا منافسين محتمرين
توفوا مثل شاهرودي
واخرين فلذلك الان
يعني
الوراثه ليست جديده حتى
توقعاتك حول هذا الاسم بالتحديد ما رايك
سيد حسن هل تتفق مع سيد صالح بانه مشتبه
قد يكون هو الخليفه القادم وان كان نعم
اين يقف بين الطرفين بين الجيش ورجال
الدين
ليس من السهل الاجابه بنعم او لا حول هذه
المساله لانها اكثر تعقيدا
وذهب اليه الاستاذ صالح ان اتفق معه بجزء
لا اختلف ولكن
القراءه اخرى حول علاقه الحرس بالمؤسسه
الدينيه ولكن فيما يتعلق بمجتبى
لا اعتقد ان الامكانيه تمرير مجتبى للموقع
المرشد
سهله او في هذه المرحله
زادت تعقيدا اكثر او صعوبه لذلك من
المحتمل ومن الارجح ايضا ان تذهب الامور
الى مجلس قياده قد يكون مشتبه جزء منه في
المستقبل ولكن ليس صاحب القرار النهائي
بانتظار وهي قد تكون مرحله انتقاليه
لاخر اخر مراحل التعايش بين المؤسسه
العسكريه او مؤسسه الحرس مع المؤسسه
الدينيه في الس وليس في الحوزه او كغطاء
ديني وشرعي للحرس
ولكن في السلطه في اليات القرار في مفاصل
النظام قد تكون اخر مراحل هي المرحله
المرحله الانتقاليه قد تكون اخر مراحل
التعايش بين الطرفين
المؤسسه العسكريه
ستذهب الى الامساك بكل مفاصل القرار وتحدد
من يكون على الراس لانهم لا يمكن ان
يخرجوا على على الدستور الذي فرض موقع
المرشد الاعلى او ولي الفقيه سيحتفظون به
ولكن هناك
سيدور الجدل حول صلاحيات هذا المرشد وكيف
ستكون والى اي حد
يسمح له بالتدخل وبالامساك بالملفات
وبالقرارات يعني المرشد القادم او المرشد
الثالث لن يكون بنفس صلاحيات المرشد
الحالي او او المؤسس لذلك هذا هذا
الهدف او المغزى من الكلام حول انتهاء
التعايش بين الط وليس الغاء الموقع
سيبقى ولكن بصلاحيات محدده ربما
ربما لنفرض جدلا لنسلم جدلا بانه القادم
سيكون بيدل الجيش حضرتك تعلم بان الحرس
الثوري الايراني
لا خصوصيه يعني لا نتحدث عن جيش منفصل عن
العقيده نحن نتحدث عن جيش وليد الحركه
حركه 1979 وبالتالي حتى رجاله كذلك لهم
انتماءات فكيف يمكن الحديث عن هذه المؤسسه
بمفصل عن الدين هل هذا دقيق هذا ممكن
ليس صعبا
اذا لم يكن ممكن فليس صعبا
ان تاخذ تتحول هذه المؤسسه الى مؤسسه
ممسكه بالنظام وبالقرار السياسي
وستستخدم يعني انا قلت انه لا يمكن ان
تذهب الى تعديل الدستور واخراج موقع
المرشد الاعلى ستكون بحاجه الى هذا الموقع
لاعطاء نفسها الصبغه الدينيه والصبغه
الاسلاميه
الشموليه التي تتجاوز الحدود الايرانيه في
نشاطاتها وهي المبدا الذي اشار اليه
الاستاذ صالح بان التسميه
الحرس ليس فيها اسم ايران ولكن الاسلاميه
الثوره الاسلاميه حرس الثوره الاسلاميه
يعني هي هنا يكمن الغطاء
للانشطه التي يقوم بها الحرس خارج الحدود
الايرانيه وفي الاقليم لذلك بحاجه الى
غطاء ديني يتحكم به وليس
المرشد الذي يتحكم بالحرس ولكن
الحرس يتحكم بالمرش سيد صالح نحن نتحدث عن
نظام امسك بالحكم لما من الخمس وثلاثين
سنه وبالتالي الداخل الايراني كيف
يقارب او كيف يرى هذا المنعطف كيف يقيمه
في هذه المرحله اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن طلاق
فعلي بين الطرفين
يعني اولا
اريد ان اعود قليلا الى قضيه مستقبل الحرس
الثوري الحقيقه يعني الان الحرس الثوري
بمفرده ليس لديه ايدولوجيه او برنامج
سياسي على الحكم انما ينفذ اوامر المؤسسه
الدينيه والسياسيه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى يعني الدستور صحيح انه دستور اسلامي
وظاهره شكليا
ديمقراطي وفي مؤسسه لكن عمليا منذ بدايه
الثوره
لم يتم العمل به ولا حتى
في عهد الخميني وايضا
[موسيقى]
المفترض
ان يكون وليا او ولي فقيه او مرشد مؤقت
لفتره انتقاليه ثم يختار مجلس الخبراء لكن
باتفاق معروف سنجاني وبعض كبار مجلس خبراء
ابقوه على المنصبيه واستمر لحد الان
فانتهاك الدستور شيء طبيعي في ظل هذا
النظام الذي لا يحترم لا الاعراف السياسيه
حيث قاموا بتصفيه كل من اتوا به في الثوره
من احزاب يساريه والليبراليه والقومات
وغيرها وهذا ايضا غير مستبعد اذا ما جاء
من قبل حرس الثوري بمجتبى خامني يمكن
تعديل الدستور ببساطه او يعني التلاعب به
كما فعل والده الاخامنه عندما وصل السلطه
واستمر بها وحتى اعتراضات احمد خميم نجل
خميني لم تنفع وربما تم تصفيته حسب ما
يقول بعض الشخصيات اذا هذه العلاقه اعتقد
انها ستستمر وايران تتحول من دوله
يعني دستور ومؤسسات وفق ما كان تطمح عليه
الثوره الى دوله فيوقراطيه بنظام القائد
بحاله اشبه بكوريا الشماليه
ومن يمسك
بالسلطه هو شخص واحد المرشد ومن يحافظ على
النظام هو حرس اشبه بكوريا الشماليه
تنقصها فقط القنبله النوويه طيب سنبقى في
متابعه هذا الموضوع اود شكركم يا جزيل
الشكر من بيروت حسن فحص الكاتب الصحفي ومن
الرياض صالح حميد الباحث في شان الايراني
شكرا جزيلا لكما